hey guys my name is Jess McDonald you
are watching games but use it's the
third of the third and gabe newell is
hosting in the am a massive troll or
actually revealing half-life 3 you let
me know seriously let me know cuz this
muses shot in advance if you're holding
out for details on infamous second son
you'll be happy to hear that it's all
ready to go Sucker Punch's action game
has gone gold ahead of its launch on
March 21 co-founder bryan fleming
confirmed the news via twitter but
unlike respawn six exclamation marks he
elected to use only two next up mass
effect may be coming to the Xbox one and
ps4 according to some Bioware rumblings
responding to a question on Twitter
where apparently all news is breaking in
Birken these days Bioware Edmonton and
Montreal general manager Ehren Flynn
said they've discussed creating new
generation versions of the trilogy
internally and if they can come up with
the solid plan they'll share it
Microsoft may have cottoned on to a new
way to make games look awesome and it's
all about real-time ray tracing what
that mild tongue twister refers to is an
advanced system which is used to achieve
photo realistic lighting effects exec
Phil Spencer is said again through
Twitter that they're in the process of
experimenting with the tech if you want
to get an idea of what it looked like
that the video demonstration of Nvidia's
Kepler real-time ray tracing system on
YouTube now theoretically the tech could
give a decent boost to the xbox one's
visuals but let me know whether you
think it'll be enough to put the
graphics more to bed last up Gabe Newell
is holding an ama on reddit right now or
at least she was 1pm as you can tell the
script is written pretty early in the
day everyone's going crazy because
Newell is holding the AMA on the third
of the third at 1300 hours which all
smacks of you'll either playing a semi
cruel joke on die hard halflife fans or
actually planning to reveal something
you probably know which one of these it
is by now so leave me your favorite
Newell revelation in the comments all
feel free to mourn the lack of half-life
3 and head over to our shiny missing in
action feature on gamespot and YouTube
to feel a little
better about all those games we never
heard from again remember as i'm sure
you all do to leave me your thoughts
feelings comments and what have you
either in the comments down below or you
can do so on my Twitter where i'm at
jeff mcdonald those are all the things
that i wanted to tell you about today
but be sure to join me again tomorrow
for more news and thank you for watching